الطبيب قد يتسبب بوفاه شخص واحد لكن
المهندس المعماري قد يتسبب بمقتل المئات
هذه النظريه اثبتها الزلزال الذي ضرب
سوريا وتركيا يقول خبير الزلازل الياباني
يوشينوريت الذي اكد حقيقه خلال مداخله على
احدى القنوات التركيه ان السماح للمقاولين
ببناء الابنيه المرتفعه والتساهل معهم
تسبب بكوارث خلال الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
في السادس من الشهر الجاري الخبير
الياباني قارن بين الانشاءات في بلاده
وبين تركيا قائلا ان طوكيو لا تسمح
للمهندسين بالبناء فور تخرجهم بل انهم
يخضعون لاختبارات ودورات طويله ومن ينال
المرتبه الاولى يسمح له بممارسه المهنه
والبناء اما البقيه فيمنعون من ذلك ايضا
اضاف انه في تركيا المقاولون هم من يشيدون
الابنيه العاليه وناطحات السحاب ويكون دور
المهندس المدني والمعماري في تركيا ثانويا
وربما غير مؤثر ودائما وفقا هذا الخبير
بالحديث مشاهدينا عن الزلازل في اليابان
تقيم المؤسسات التعليميه بشكل سنوي تجارب
فرضيه لوقوع زلزال ليتعلم الطلاب منذ
صغرهم على التصرف السليم مع الكوارث
الطبيعيه وسنتابع هذا الفيديو من احدى تلك
الورش
[موسيقى]
هذه المقارنه تسمنت مع تحضيرات داخل تركيا
في التسرع في اعاده اعمار بناء ما تم
تدميره خلال الزلزال وهو ما وعد به الرئيس
اردوغان الذي وضع مده زمنيه اقصاها عام
واحد لاعاده اعمار المدمر من المنازل
وافقت تحذيرات التي خرجت عن المهندسين
وخبراء بناء ان التسرع ينذر بوقوع كارثه
اخرى اما لم تتم اعاده النظر بعنايه في
التخطيط الحضري وايضا سلامه المباني وهو
ايضا ما اكدته سين كويمين الرئيسه السابقه
لغرفه المهندسين المعماريين في اسطنبول
قائله ان احلال المباني المهدمه هو
الضروري فحسب بل ما يهم هو اعاده تخطيط
المدن بناء على البيانات العلميه مثل عدم
البناء على خطوط الصداع وتعلم الدروس من
اخطاء الماضيه واضافت ان التخطيط الجديد
يجب ان يتصدر الاولويات وليس البناء